Kim house is a competition reality show
where 10 cam girls will live together
for eight weeks oh what could go wrong
throw 10 crazy in a house together it's
like
Hi how are you ladies oh hi hi my name
is Liliana hi hi you guys's name I'm
Sophia um I'm really looking for frenzy
you want to be my friend uh sure
she does not want to be your friend I
was very
it's tough for them they gotta think
this is tough enough beds for everyone
here
[Laughter]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today I was sent
and only fans reality show I don't know
why you guys like to torture me I don't
know why this is fun for you but I guess
today I'm gonna react to these amazing
smart accomplished women in a reality
show um let's let's pull up the video
[Music]
welcome to cam house I'm your host Emily
Jones and I've been a cam model for over
four years and now I'm looking for the
next Rising Star oh my God why would you
do this to me we're calling cam models a
rising star really
Kim house is a competition reality show
where 10 cam girls will live together
for eight weeks oh what could go wrong
throw 10 crazy [__] in a house
together they will compete in Dynamic
challenges in order to win a cash prize
of ten thousand dollars I mean what are
you competing like who can be the best
[__]
[Music]
and a chance to sign with our sponsor
yum Model Management during their time
here you the audience at home will get
to vote with your dollars oh thank God I
get to vote join in each week to tip for
your favorite cam girl the one who earns
the most is safe from elimination at the
end of eight weeks only one girl will be
left standing this is Camp House
is this where we've gone in society we
have Cam house instead of the bachelor
they're not even trying I like to think
of these things like these could be
wives mothers
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
it felt amazing to be the first one in
the house I was so thrilled I love my
alone time so it was so nice to be the
first one in the home to look at the
beautiful home and see all the beautiful
things inside of it
oh
well first of all the house is gorgeous
oh hi I just feel this good my name is
Caitlin calming presents coming inside
and I just think it's gonna be a magical
time so much energy Sophia I'm your
company when has a bunch of [__]
living in a house together resulted in a
magical time did you guys not grow up
watching America's Next Top Model nobody
Bachelor no one listen can we be friends
yeah sure it's nice to meet you
um nice to meet you I love the colored
streaks in your hair I was so excited
when I saw Sophie walk in you know more
girls the competition and it made me
feel like I could really win this thing
so
I'm shocked every multiple personality
I'm shocked personalities to arrive
honestly Caitlyn kind of didn't pass the
vibe check
she kind of had a tude yeah trying to
get the biggest bed I'm just trying to
get my own room I don't need to share
with everyone else I need plenty of
space for my aura I can see that yeah
where is the attitude this is like women
it's all based on how we feel so if we
feel there's an attitude that then
there's an attitude it's like
Hi how are you ladies oh hi hi my name
is Liliana hi hi you guys Zane I'm
Sophia um I'm really looking for friends
do you want to be my friend uh sure
she does not want to be your friend I
was very excited I'm Caitlin it's nice
to meet you oh nice to meet you I love
your hat oh thank you I like it as well
um do you know where my room is at my
mom's we haven't really chosen them yet
but we were here first so we're gonna
have first dibs on beds oh okay we'll
we'll see about that I didn't like
seeing the other girls but I mean it's
no competition when I see the other
girls so you know it's good your
competition to be a [__] really really
gorgeous I love your blonde hair I mean
I like the the hair yeah
um I usually pick one streak for how I'm
feeling on the day but like I'm really
excited because I don't know what to
expect so I have like every color okay
yeah perfect
[Music]
wow oh my gosh this is such a beautiful
house
I can't believe I'm here
this is amazing I'm gonna like touch
everything it's so nice I've never seen
a house this big before really yeah oh
I'm from like a small town so we don't
really have like
big extravagance oh so sorry yeah well
coming from a small town I was a little
nervous I've never been to Miami so it's
a big city I didn't know what to expect
but the house was beautiful oh well do
you have a lot of friends in your small
town
um I usually hang out with like horses
and dogs but it sounds like fun is that
your friends like the horses and dogs
I cannot wait to see what's about to
happen here
[Music]
entering the house for the first time
was really cool the house is beautiful
another new face a lot of Personality
how are you it's how
nice yeah girl right
did you see the pool yet oh my gosh oh
my god did he bring your bathing suit it
was cool to see everyone in the house
too for the first time you could tell
all the other ladies were excited so
just feeding off of that energy was
it was it was dope it was fun I liked it
and then like I'd rather just do my
thing and see who followed things
seriously
it's such a beautiful house I mean I'm
just excited to get to meet everyone and
have the best time I can I mean some of
the girls are iffy but the house is
beautiful I love it do you have two face
they're all like hi oh my God my gosh
they're like no vibe check um what is a
Vibe I'm so tired of hearing about Vibes
oh I'm a singer oh yeah oh yeah I do
that like on cruise ships for several
years and I get to travel around the
world and it was super fun and I got to
meet all these people so I walk in the
house for the very first time and I'm
just starting to get to know the girls
and I want it to be a good experience I
want the energy to be good so I'm
bringing my a game my personality I want
to get to know everybody out of bed
getting up I have not even gotten to
like my normal energy level yet you know
what do you put in your yeah what do you
put in your coffee what do you mean and
like right away everybody's a little
standoffish and I'm like this is gonna
be a long couple of days if nobody
really wants to get to know each other
and I'm the only one asking questions so
I wouldn't want to get to know you
either I just I'd be in my room like I'm
putting myself out there and trying to
make friends try trying to build
camaraderie and they're giving me
nothing to work with
all right shock ham girls don't make the
best friend I'm flabbergasted ladies go
ahead and take a seat
hi everyone I'm Emily and I'm your host
and as you know this is Camp house all
of you will be competing against one
another for a ten thousand dollar cash
prize as well as the chance to sign to
Yum Model Management
so as you've probably noticed as you've
come in there's that's kind of crazy
I've heard that the best only fans
models like that make the most money are
just like different degrees of mid and
based on the women that have showed up
for this seems like a hundred percent
true because I guess if you're like a
six then you're like more appealing to
like the bottom guys because I guess
most of the guys watching only fans are
like the bottom like virgin men and so
if you're a six like five then you're
like hot to them that's what I've heard
not enough beds for everyone here
hahaha
I'm so easy going I would just take the
couch but they're all gonna [__] I
would just be like whatever that means
that we are going to jump you know it's
crazy I'll tell you guys they gave up my
room when I moved out
um my parents they gave it to my sister
I know and I sleep on the couch all the
time when I go home it just is what it
is who's above a couch who's above it
the
right into our first mini challenge oh
it's a Challenger we're all going to
have to make a viral Tick Tock video
we're going to be looking at the person
with the most views and the most likes
anyone who makes the best most viral
video will get the exclusive upstairs
Suite
anyone who comes in second is going to
get the master bedroom after that the
four of you are going to have to share a
bedroom together all week and whoever
loses is going to be banished to the
outdoor shed with no bed all week long
so make sure I can make it work where I
can make it work you don't even
understand guys you don't okay I grew up
with nine siblings okay and we would go
on these road trips when I was a kid and
drive like I'm talking like 20 30 hours
and in the car and my dad my dad's like
a trooper he literally would just drive
from like Chicago to Oregon like through
the night like my dad is just built
different and we would all sleep on like
the ground of the van like you don't
even understand you learn to sleep on
the floor you figure you get a little
blanket you figure it out it's fine do
you guys have a script and are ready to
make your first viral Tick Tock everyone
good yeah great I'll see you ladies
later
I know that you guys want to like be
chit chatting all day but I think I'm
gonna go uh get started with my Tick
Tock cause I ain't sleeping in the jet
let's do it I'm here to win so yeah
[Music]
Tick Tock challenge I could kill that
challenge guys I used to kill I got
banned but I I was a I was a master tick
tocker okay ideas well I know that I
need a room by myself because I don't
want to hear anybody snoring so I have
to think of something good I am not
sleeping in that shed there's just
nowhere okay we have to do something fun
something that nobody's ever thought of
before
thank you
what would I do no I don't wanna I don't
want to give only only fans models might
watch this and use my awesome ideas I
don't want to give I have idea I gotta I
know
this is tough for them they gotta think
this is tough
[Music]
hey guys I'm gonna be doing a tick tock
dance let me go ahead how do you like
the intro that I have oh it was great
you love it yeah you're killing it like
I am so proud of you perfect I I'm I'm
really proud thank you oh awesome all
about friendship right yeah is this real
this seems kind of staged I don't how's
the lighting in your angle honestly it's
not so great you know what I'm what are
you thinking about are you thinking what
I'm thinking I think we should collab
okay
I am so excited going into the tick tock
challenge because I was with Liliana and
I thought this was my first opportunity
to make a really good friend in the
house we were I don't I don't get friend
vibes from the brunette chick the right
uh I just don't see this going well all
paired together and I got that
one-on-one time kind of drawing I'm like
what's on Tick Tock right now a lot of
dancing oh like some disco fever like oh
yeah maybe not 80 these at first I
didn't really know how working with
Sophia would work I think Naomi finally
opened up and she's a kind of a little
stale on the personality Department like
not a lot going there I'm starting to
question if this is real I think I think
this might be fast forward like 30 years
oh like swag money the thing is just
like Sophia has her own thing going on
as far as creative Direction so working
with her was interesting to say the
least
I mean like a lot of like rocking side
to side oh gosh icelands chest movement
yeah how about I do the dance okay and
then you can like I'll commentate
[Music]
[Applause]
and like work together and it'll be yeah
dope as the kids say something like that
um
[Music]
actually this is so smart okay you know
I'm thinking like the lighting is really
tough here it is um like it's just why
don't I angle you and then we can just
switch it around
but instead of making it about the
Friendship instead of us working
together and collabing because there
were two opportunities for people to get
their own rooms she purposely tried to
sabotage me of course
[Laughter]
she took my kindness and my enthusiasm
and my friendliness as me being dumb be
dramatic cool come on oh perfect
okay so let's see for the ones we do
together we should get like I haven't
even heard one creative idea uh see I
I'm thinking of I'm thinking of ideas of
what I would do I mean I wouldn't do the
cam stuff but I'm like you got to be a
relatable only fans model like I'm just
thinking like and all they're doing is
these stupid dances and selfies it's
like have some creativity chicks I know
outside the box
okay we'll get a yoga mat and we'll put
the yoga mat down and we'll do one of
those videos where it's like we'll do a
pose and then we start dancing I love it
I love it all right sounds good I'll get
my mat we'll map it out all right we got
it I didn't really like the challenge
but
whatever how it goes I guess oh my God
Tick Tock is going viral all these
emojis they're Harding you and sending
you gifts and coins and she took my
phone and she tried to purposely
sabotage my Tick Tock okay yeah flip
your hair if you want to do your thing
well that was an accident but I mean the
camera flipped on me like it should
um but you know it worked out I guess
all righty and we're good
oh yeah look at that swag money oh
[Applause]
well I think this is the worst thing
I've ever seen in my life I don't know
why you guys are torturing me you know
as as a creative I'm just honestly
disappointed by the lack of creativity
originality anything like if you're
gonna be a sex worker at least be a good
sex worker and you can learn the names
yeah
I think that's the one I think that's a
winner I think we're gonna win this
challenge we might we better I see with
my use of props and personality all
right the best one I've seen I think
maybe the yoga mat seems the best but
they all kind of suck so it's like
battle for the worst you know charm and
wit and just amazingness I think we did
great this has got to be trolling this
has got to be true well I actually felt
really good because I'm not really
familiar I think she's do you think
she's the hottest King I think she's the
best looking maybe you're the brunette
so she might win just like doing some
mouth like you know lip syncing they do
on Tick Tock and win with Tick Tock so
when I was by myself I kind of explored
the app and I found out it was really
fun and I really enjoyed my time outside
alone
I don't know what I'm doing but
[Music]
um
all right terrible the the first my
prediction is Blondie
all right that's just bad light like as
a as a cameraman King like this is what
is this lighting like they can't even
like she why doesn't she go on the
window like that's the simplest
I will give you my phone of course and
then this way you can record me and the
lighting will be like hey there
everybody it is
Alex favorite
it's so exciting okay so she got sabot
maybe that one
hi girls thank you so much for coming
back and we have reviewed your Tick Tock
challenge all right and we I'm gonna
guess blonde chick wins what's your
guess yeah know who the winner and the
losers are and who is going to get beds
and who's not going to get beds this
week so but they didn't show all of them
dinner they're probably sparing us of
this challenge is
[Applause]
it made me feel really happy because I
thought I wasn't going to be able to win
and I did win you're going to be getting
the master suite upstairs and what was
her take time the room was amazing it's
like the perfect room for me it came
with a bunch of books inside and I
really needed to be alone I love my
alone time so it just made me feel
awesome like I really can win this thing
so all smiles next Alyssa
you are going to be getting the
downstairs bedroom all to yourself I was
actually thinking because that was a
unique like video I was actually
thinking maybe her yeah
next the people who are oh that girl's
so pissed seem to be sharing the bedroom
together are Sophia
Kaylee Liliana and Naomi
and that means that I guess I was wrong
about Blondie that was my guess Hannah
you will be outside in the shed by
yourself with no bed
I thought I did really well but
apparently I did the word side of it can
you imagine getting last in a tick tock
competition like can you imagine that's
your like low point and she's the
youngest one it's like in that like
beauty or isn't that currency you lost
to a 29 year old which is like hitting
the wall full fledge this is just sad oh
this is so sad which I still think isn't
true I think there's no way Sophia beat
me honestly I think for the first week
I'm okay with sharing your room because
I can scope out my competition thank you
girls so much for participating and we
will see you
wow guys
um thank you for torturing me with that
I'm traumatized by one the lack of
creativity I'm just saying if you're
going to be a creative be a creative
um two by I really think they're
trolling they can't be this idiot like
they just can't anyways um let me know
what you guys think in the comments was
I wrong I thought I thought the Blondie
was gonna get top tick tocker but you
know I'm on the edge of my seat you know
guys let me know in the comments if you
want to torture me with another episode
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel I'll talk to you next
time